I want you to say about two different
countries are competing to see which can
have a better economy now one of the
countries encourages parents to teach
their kids about concepts of
entrepreneurship and the other one does
it which country economy do you think is
going to create more jobs I'm willing to
bet this country here so today in this
episode I'm going to talk about 17
different things you could do to help
raise your kids into entrepreneurs so
before going into it if you got any
questions thoughts or comments about
what I talked about comment on the
bottom and if you have not yet
subscribed to value team and click on
the subscribe button here before I get
into the video so let me get right into
it 17 model before I get into it I got
three kids myself so anything I'm
teaching you I'm teaching it to my kids
as well number one tell stories let me
take what I mean by telling stories I
will go to a simple restaurant and I'll
ask if the owners are there
I'll have them come by and I'll say
hello to them in front of my kids
then I'll say hey Tico hey Dilli do you
see that man over there yes that man
saved all his money in his life and
started this restaurant so you and I can
eat and this restaurant pays that
waitress pays that cook pays this person
so can you imagine that risk that man
took created all these people jobs and
all these people feed their families
because that man was an entrepreneur no
way daddy yes I tell these stories all
the time always the stories about what
it is we're creating jobs what it is to
become entrepreneurs and the kids are
always fascinated that's the man that's
the man that's the man that owns this
business oh my gosh daddy number to
teach value of money so what is value of
money you make 10 bucks $1 goes to you
giving it away to somebody $1 goes
towards taxes I'm apparently the
government at the house I get the tax
this kind of works out I give them 10 I
take $1 back then the eight goes into
their savings plan and I explain this is
how it works when you make money you
give one to somebody you give one into
taxes and you keep a to yourself daddy I
don't want to pay taxes I said daddy I
don't want to pay taxes well we have to
pay taxes because we have certain things
that we take advantage of you're living
in this house you have a room someone's
cooking for you this is a government if
we were a country this is the country
I'm the president
true you have to pay me a dollar in
taxes we teach these concepts to them
about money number three gift versus
ownership I think this is a very
important concept to learn about the
difference between gift and ownership
but sometimes like I'll give a gift to
my kid and I'll say to my kid listen I'm
giving this to you as a kid because I
want to give it to you right I said but
Tico dilly if you buy this thing with
your own money you will play with it
more because you took your own money
into it and they fully don't understand
you of what I'm talking about but I'm
telling them that anyways we were in Bal
Harbour a couple weeks ago Miami and my
middle son Dylan my youngest son Dylan
sees a white Ferrari says daddy I want
you to buy that Ferrari for me I said
daddy I'm gonna do you one better pop
this is what is it I someone teach you
how you can buy the white Ferrari for
yourself he was absolutely furious he
said daddy I want you to buy daddy I
said no you're gonna buy because if you
buy you'll take care of it better more
than if I buy it for you and then he's
listening he's understanding all this
stuff none of this stuff may make any
sense to them right now but it's
sticking some of this stuff is sticking
number four compensation plan I think
everybody ought to have some sort of a
compensation plan you have it as an
adult you may be a teenager watching
this may be a parent watching this at
your job you get paid a salary that's
your compensation plan and if you do X Y
Z you you get a bonus in our country no
matter what country you live in there's
a tax system the tax system is a
compensation plan you make fifty
thousand dollars you pay fifteen percent
in taxes you make a hundred thousand
dollars you pay forty-three percent in
taxes you make a quarter million dollars
you pay fifty seven and a half percent
but there's a compensation plan to you I
always have a compensation plan with
toys out buy in advance if I go into the
apply people people say I'm never buying
toys in them all I always buy them but
here's what I do with the toys I buy I
display them all the way on the top of
my house at the top of a place where no
one can raise your 12 feet up they can't
reach it but they see it every single
day and they're coming at that daddy I
want to play with that toy I have toys
on the wall for eight nine ten twenty
week
that they keep seeing the bigger the toy
the longer it takes to get it because
they got to do more work what do I need
to do then it's behavior responsibility
doing your chores doing your part early
in the morning playing practice and
doing this doing that there's a
compensation you do X Y Z you get this
we have a compensation plan number five
teach capitalism Pat you teach capital
them to your kids always what do you
mean you teach capitalism to your kids
do you sit there and teach them it forms
of economy and what's the difference
between socialism and communism and all
this other stuff when they're at my at
the Asia they already know five and
three what I explained to them is
capitalism is all about who does it
better and who treats people better if
you create a product that's better than
somebody else or if you treat people
better than others are treating their
people you'll win long term oh so treat
people better you win
create something better you win now if
these kids get to eight nine ten years
old and we're sitting there doing math
with them and all this other stuff I'm
going to explain the difference between
capitalism socialism and communism and
how it benefits that if you put a lot of
hard work in and capitalism you win if
you wait for everybody else to give them
their stuff to you you're not going to
win and I'll explain here that you won't
own anything I'll explain you do you
want to own your own car do you want to
own your own house you can't do that in
communism do you want to be able to make
money and you keep a big part of the
money you don't have to give sixty
percent of the way yes
socialism you give sixty percent away
capitalism you keep 70 percent of it
thirty percent goes sometimes it's
higher than that but preferably a big
part stays with you depending on the tea
age I'm going to get deeper into that
number six recognize and when they
create a job when they create money when
they make a profit when they do chore
better when they create something better
hey buddy good job with that man I'm
proud of you that was good stuff good
stuff you did right there with your
little business you undo some good stuff
here with this business given that
encouragement and recognize afford and
try to do it in front of a lot of other
people your family mom hey did you see
pop what he did hey did you see grandma
what he did hey did you see what he did
you're building up their identity and
they want more of that because it's
recognition seven challenge early I
think I started challenging Tico
at a year and a half two years old and I
literally will sit there I'll get on my
knees their head is always above me
anytime I'm challenging their dad has to
be above me so they have to be looking
here so at least they feel superior so I
put them up in our laundry room we have
a poet you say four feet how high is
that thing four feet so I put Tico and
dylan there and they look like this to
me and I ask him can I tell you what you
were thinking when you did that and I'll
challenge him on it can I tell you what
you were thinking with this part here
early any reason why I didn't want to do
this explain it to me I'm curious what
were you thinking here and I'm
challenging early the reason why I'm
challenging early I think sometimes
parents don't challenge early and then
all of a sudden they do then the kids
don't like their parents I'm challenging
earlier now obviously a year and a half
it's a different challenge in
two-and-a-half then five and a half then
ten and 16 it's going to be a different
challenge as a level of maturity goes
you got to allow them to be the adults
and speak to them like adults but a lot
sooner you give them respect the sooner
they'll respond so I challenge very
early the world of business it's all
about challenging the world of business
entrepreneurship it's all over always
about you getting better so you always
got to have that early on teach proper
values you can pick and choose whatever
values you want to teach for me it's
four of them that I teach on a daily
basis I ask Tico and Dylan hey what are
the four things we do as a family daddy
we lead we improve we respect we love so
adaptive Tommy lead improve respect love
lead respect improve love lead risk they
say this to me so many times asking this
morning what do we do such-and-such so
if they don't respect somebody and they
do behavior that's how I set them out
and say hey in this situation here did
you respect the other person no do you
want to be respected yes anyway somebody
didn't respect them I don't know daddy
any reason why I didn't do it hey what
do we do as a family lead did you lead
in this situation I did not I want you
to lead in this situation because we're
the David family we lead hey buddy you
know what happened today what happened I
don't care if you don't you didn't win
the game today but you improved today
because what I want the four things that
we do improve you improve today good job
so I'm confident teaching that I'm
Constitution about not bullying and not
getting bullied sometimes we only teach
about not bullying other people we
forget to teach that don't let
others bull you as well this is a big
part of business excit shut all the time
number nine repetition you know you
can't say the same thing enough times I
think sometimes as I'm doing weekly
conference calls or if I'm mentoring or
building other entrepreneurs one of the
things I will tell them I'll say you're
probably going to hear me say this 50
100 200 more times and you'll probably
hear me saying this five 10 20 30 years
from now because business is about
repetition and reira minding re
reminding and repetition is about re
reminding you can't just say one thing
one time and it's going to stick with
them re reminding re reminding and
that's a part of repetition number 10
environment if your kids are going to be
in an environment where there's other
people selling talking about business
they're going to pick it up if your kids
are friends with other kids whose
parents are also business owners those
habits are typically being passed on to
their kids so they're generally being
taught the same mindset I like my kids
to be friends with other parents kids
other kids whose parents run businesses
because they understand hard work and
effort and all that stuff so environment
is very very important I like to bring
my kids to the environment if we do
conferences I want them to be around it
I want them to see the languages that's
being spoken because they're picking it
up even though you don't think they're
picking it up how many times to hear an
adult 28 I have one of my friends Jose
would say my mother used to be in a
company called Shaklee she would always
sell dadada and I remember I would watch
my mom selling stuff and my mom would
sell jewelry or my mom would sell this
that stays six years old eight years old
these kids remember they're gonna
remember what you're doing with them as
well eleven books five dollars you read
this book you write a paper you
presented in front of family you get
five bucks this book is three times
bigger this is a fifteen dollar book you
read this book you write a paper you
presented to the family I asked you
questions about the book because I'm
making sure you're not getting this off
Google or you're not getting a summary I
know you read the book and I'm gonna ask
you specific questions to see if you
know the answers if you know the test
then you get your $15 books early on if
you can get them reading simple business
books early on they'll have an edge over
other people number twelve
how they would solve a problem let you
say something happens in a house let you
say something happens in the country let
you say something happens to the
community let's say something happens to
sibling let's say something happens to
help hey how would you have handled that
how would you solve that problem Oh
daddy I would probably do this and then
I would do that and then I would call
Batman and I would have Batman called
Superman and we would solve it together
because Super Mario would show up with
Inspector Gadget I don't care what
they're saying but I want them to be
thinking about how they're going to be
solving that problem oh no way that's
crazy that's awesome kid you solve a
problem like that I would solver like
that daddy
okay good you're smart you know how to
leverage other people and bring help yes
because Batman is going to help me out
now that's that five at eleven years old
going to get some reasonable answers but
what I'm telling you is ask the question
anyways
thirteen teacher kids sales teach you
how to sell now when you teach them how
to sell and negotiate they're typically
going to do with you in the next two to
three years okay so just be prepared
because my son Tico is a very good
negotiator he is just a brilliant
negotiator he's five years old right he
knows how to negotiate and Dylan has a
different tactic of sales and his
brother does but they know how to sell
and I want to teach that early on
because everything in life is going to
be selling every single thing a kid who
knows how to sell better than another
kid will typically move up in life
faster as long as they have the effort
because they know how to get them
substance situations that somebody else
doesn't know how to do so teach sales
early number fourteen let them see you
in action I don't mind my three I
remember I eighteen month old son will
listen to me on conference calls and he
would just look at me I'm doing a
conference called the kid is sitting
right in front of me he's letting me
doing conference calls conference calls
if I have a negotiation call I'd have
them sit down or listen to me if I had a
strong conversation I'd have them sit
down or listen to me they're hearing me
constantly and the more they're human
they're going to remember this stuff
five 10 15 20 years later fifteen speak
about failure and mistakes hey buddy let
me tell you story about what happened
with johnny wants Johnny used to do this
and this is what happened to him hey let
me tell you by the story of an old
friend of mine hey let me tell you story
about what happened with this kid hey
let me tell you a story about this actor
hey let me tell you a story about this
always tell stories of failure and
mistakes that you may
eight and others made to educate him
through that and it saves them the time
to not make those mistakes everyone can
talk about keys to success that's easy I
like to talk about mistakes and failures
number 16 if you're too hard on them and
you're too serious with them they won't
enjoy the process - I want them to enjoy
it
it's just like math I want you to enjoy
math math is so cool I want you to enjoy
business it's a game you know you're
like playing a game I'll tell them you
know how you like to play this game
daddy business is a game and if you
learn how to play this business game
it's so easy daddy boy it's so easy oh
my gosh I want to learn daddy daddy this
thing is such an easy game I'm going to
teach you if you want to learn I want to
learn no problem daddy we're going to
learn this business game together so the
serious stuff let them experience that
stuff because business series is going
to hit you pretty hard you're teaching
I'm all read about failures and mistakes
you know you're teaching the principles
already as well but don't go to series
where they forget the fact that it's a
fun game that they can play as well and
last but not least your example and the
language you use will have a massive
amount of effect on your kids what's
language if your kids can't say humor
you're talking about you're in pain I'm
tired my body hurts I hate my boss I
can't stand my job you have no idea what
they did to me if they constantly hear
that I'm tired they want to be like you
mommy I'm also tired I hate my boss
mommy I also hate my boss I can't stand
what's happened mommy I also can they're
just going to mimic you okay they're
just going to mimic you so if you say
hey pop listen we get we get we're going
to be fine we're going to do this good
things are happening we're going places
here's what we're going to be doing
mommy's working hard right now the
reason why mommy's working hard right
now because you said you want to go to
Disney World and we're going to go
together today's in worlds in July hey
daddy's working hard on it because
together remember we went to the beach
one time I'm going to take you to Hawaii
we're going to go to Cancun we're going
to go to Europe where you're going to
see the Statue you're going to see the
sky Alexander the Great where we read
about that one time you're going to see
what he walked out Acropolis in Athens
no way that is yeah daddy boy we're
going to go it's going to be amazing
with so this is why that it works are
oh okay daddy but I'm going to play with
you on Sunday daddy boy okay pop so all
this stuff that you're doing I'm just
telling you what I'm doing okay some of
this stuff you may say it's absolutely
ludicrous I'll never do it I totally
understand some of the stuff I do is
probably it's not probably it is
ludicrous but some of the stuff you may
do is going to work for you and if there
are some things that you're doing with
your kids that I didn't cover comment on
the bottom and if you haven't sub to
this click on the subscribe button a my
challenge to you is this if you got kids
watch this all over again
and start implementing some of these
things in your own personal life and if
you have other people who have kids
parents and all that stuff
share this video with them and tack
somebody on the video if it's on
Facebook or share with them so they can
also get some of these principles for
themselves as well thanks for watching
everybody take care
[Music]
you